the big delusional ideology that is
being pushed right now by the liberal
establishment it's not just by the blue
haired radicals on the crazy college
campus in the middle of nowhere
this is an ideology being pushed by the
biggest corporations the biggest tech
platforms
and and the government itself
transgenderism
it's not don't forget you've got
major companies all waving the
transgender flag did you know there's a
transgender flag apparently there is
and this is everyone's celebrating this
sort of thing the actress ellen page
uh who is now calling herself elliot but
you know i think i'm going to stop doing
this i think i'm going to stop indulging
in the name changes because
we for a long time have set up we're not
going to indulge in
the pronouns because i'm not going to
call her
him you can't force me to lie some
people are doing that though some people
are going along with it or they're
they're just choosing not to use the
pronouns or they're going to use
the singular they as though you know
we've got lots of demons inside of us
and
we are legion or something but we said
okay you know
we on the conservative side we said
we're not going to go with the pronouns
but we will call them whatever name they
want if they you know
anyone can change their name that's
perfectly fine
no i don't think so caitlyn is a girl's
name
caitlyn's not a boy's name so if i refer
to caitlyn jenner as him
but i continue to refer to him as
caitlyn
i'm still kind of confusing the issue
aren't i i don't know that you can just
go along and change your name
willy-nilly like that it's a little
confusing because you've got george
eliot
one of the greatest female novelists of
all time and you've got uh
evelyn waugh it's not a lady not evelyn
you know it's not a not a gal
he's a guy so i know look there's a
little ambiguity with the names a little
more so than with the pronouns but
i think i'm going to have to go with
ellen page so ellen page posts this
photo of herself topless
this photo would not be permitted for if
any other woman did it but because
ellen page is pretending to be a man she
gets to post this picture
and she looks much more like a boy she's
had breast
mutilation she's got some abs now i
don't know if that was surgical or if
that's
uh you know from lifting weights or
something like that from doing crunches
you can tell i don't really know exactly
how these uh muscle groups are developed
that's not my thing
uh wearing men's swim trunks and saying
you know look i'm i'm a boy now look
look how happy i'm big smile on her face
all right now that i've got your
attention ring the bell ring the bell
subscribe
like make sure that you get the
notifications while you're at it by the
way
head off of youtube and go on over to
our podcast apps you know apple podcast
spotify
google play wherever you listen to your
podcasts make sure you subscribe
we've heard there's some shenanigans
going on with our subscriptions
and our our shows on those apps so just
just to make sure that there's no
glitches or anything like that head on
over subscribe
if you wouldn't mind leave a five star
review we'll see you next time